a cross-border raid apparently carried
out by ethnic Russians on Russian
territory there is much about these
images that doesn't seem to fit
yet armed men from two groups called the
Russia volunteer Corps and the liberty
of Russia Legion claimed to have
captured several Towns close to the
Ukrainian border
forward units they reported on Twitter
had entered the town of gray voron home
to a Russian military base where they
used drones to attack the local
headquarters of Russia's Security
Service the FSB these pictures cannot be
independently verified video on social
media purports to show two men making
their escape in a captured armored
vehicle
the fighters described themselves as
Russian citizens opposed to the Kremlin
they can be seen here wearing Ukrainian
Insignia in a video statement posted on
social media
we are Russians just like you we're
people just like you we want our
children to grow up in peace and be free
the statement rails against official
corruption in Russia a country described
as a dictatorship and it appears to
threaten the Kremlin directly
your support is what reminds us every
day of our final goal Red Square
the attacks sparked the evacuation of
Russian citizens from the area as the
authorities said a counter-terrorism
operation was underway these images were
later released by the defense Ministry
Russia's retaliation it said destroying
equipment and claiming the lives of
dozens of Fighters speaking to reporters
by phone the Kremlin spokesman said the
attackers were Ukrainian and suggested
the threat of incursion Justified
Russia's Invasion or special military
operation as he called it
look they are Ukrainian militants from
Ukraine there are many ethnic Russians
living in Ukraine but they are Ukrainian
militants anyway
this demands more efforts from our side
these efforts are ongoing as well as the
special military operation designed to
prevent similar incursions
in response Ukraine said it had quote
nothing to do with it Jonah Al Jazeera
moscow-based journalist Julia